bury deep in the biden administration's
proposed budget you'll find some new
politically correct language
since it's now offensive to identify
someone as a mother
that term has been replaced with
birthing people
in the section about maternal mortality
but the administration wasn't very
consistent
they go right back to using the word
mother when discussing paid leave
so which is it joining me now with all
the answers rachel campos-duffy fox and
friends
weekend co-host congratulations on that
designation
rachel and christy dahl radio host and
host he's a multiple host
host of the chris de gaulle show podcast
a man of many talents and a great show
chris i love
going on it and uh you're uh uh expert
on most things and i want to start uh
becoming to you in a minute
rachel you know we saw this uh changing
of
the word of mother in a way an erasing
of femaleness
um a few months ago i i think it was on
the senate floor it was in congress
when this was brought up and everybody
once again everybody thought it was a
joke and it was too crazy to even
like why why would be doing that but
then we naturally then see it
you know that's just the start then
that's just to prepare people to start
seeing it
um we we know what this is about it is
about the
transsexuals uh which is fine you're an
adult you want to make a change but
it's it's fascinating that they feel the
need to erase
women the concept entirely uh tell us
what you think about that
well there first of all that was
representative corey bush you're right
she was on
on the congressional floor and and she's
the one who first introduced this term
and there was some
some pushback uh and now we're seeing
exactly what you said that it's growing
and this was just a preparation look
there are some very powerful forces
that are hell-bent on erasing our gender
and in order to win this battle
tammy um pre-woke feminists you know
plenty of them
are going to have to do something very
um uncomfortable
they are going to have to join forces
with people that they generally don't
like
um conservative pro-life women and men
evangelicals um and they're going to
have to join forces
to fight this because make no mistake
this is exactly
what they want to do they want to erase
our gender they want to
erase um our femininity our our
purpose and our identity as as
procreators as
in in the creation process in the
birthing process
and so i think that we really need to
have some very interesting bedfellows
and it's going to be hard for the left
because the champions in this battle are
not the usual people they like the
planned parenthood or the national
organization of women it is
ron desantis it is donald trump it is
your local gop channel
local evangelical leaders yeah i would
say though that they don't even need to
think about joining up with anybody they
can just be honest
we are always told by the left to trust
science no one is saying that
we're not liking the transsexuals i mean
that's absurd
americans are a generous people
and you live and let live but this is
not even what
the transsexuals that i know it's like
we haven't been talking about this this
is not what we want we haven't cared
about bathrooms we don't care about this
it is another way to divide and and
liberals and democrats
need to be honest about what's going on
here that this is also not what they
voted for
not what they stand for this is
completely contrived
and it's it's unacceptable um and we can
go to
this similar situation chris uh well
that is
of course bizarre in and of itself and
nobody wants it uh
let's deal with critical race theory
because you've got an interesting
situation personally
we know that children are now being
pitted against other children they want
children to see race first
with critical race theory in in kids
schools
tell everyone what you've decided to do
about that particular situation
i have three kids two of them tammy are
in high school midway through high
school one is in sixth grade and our
youngest
our daughter in sixth grade we decided
to remove her from school over critical
race theory
we simply cannot abide in our home that
our children would be
indoctrinated with notions that we have
always taught against and that is
viewing people through
their skin color or their gender or
their sexuality first
we don't stand for that that's not what
we believe in and yet in every school
district like mine
uh the one that we chose by the way we
moved to a suburb specifically for this
district but they've installed one of
these six-figure
uh race-baiting diversity people
to inject racism in every single
curriculum
and we said no we're simply not going to
have it so we've we're going to remove
my youngest daughter
and we're going to start a new anew in a
private christian school this fall
and and that i admire that a great deal
i know uh
rachel you care about your kids
education it's important dynamic
but it is a luxury i have to say what we
are fighting for
are for everybody who is like not in the
middle class maybe struggling
financially reliant on public schools
that we we can't abandon them and this
fight is is
for everybody and i'm i'm looking
forward i think to
the fact that this kind of conversation
this is about all kids
it in fact it's not about denigrating
anybody
this is the fight against integration
actually embracing everyone so you
both of you do a great job personally
and in your work and uh thank you very
much rachel campos duffy of course
you'll see here on the weekends
and everywhere else here on fox and
christal
all over on radio philadelphia and his
podcast thanks both of you for coming on
tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else